eso
[Música]
buenas noches cómo reaccionamos cuando
frente a nuestros ojos sucede una grave
injusticia de manos un momento para
pensar algunos de ustedes pueden decir
con rechazo con indignación con ganas de
hacer algo acerté
a pesar de lo que dice nuestra lógica
esto no siempre sucede así ni en nuestro
entorno inmediato ni en el mundo podemos
encontrar un ejemplo de eso en nuestros
recuerdos del colegio algunos les
recuerda una situación de bullying hacia
algún compañero recuerdan ustedes cómo
reaccionar recuerdan si reaccionar si no
hacemos nada hacemos mucho daño
margarita cano investigadora de niñez y
juventud en colombia encontró que las
víctimas de bullying sufren el doble de
dolor por la inacción de los
espectadores que por la acción del
maltratador
el silencio de los espectadores entre
las burlas los golpes y las
humillaciones legítima amplifica ya
honda la injusticia ahora como adulto yo
me pregunto cómo era posible que pasaran
estas situaciones ante los ojos sin para
ávidos de profesores y compañeros y no
hiciéramos nada lamentablemente esto no
solamente pasa en las aulas de clase
pasa en el mundo todos podemos pensar en
alguna situación en que un grupo de
personas ha sufrido de manera
desproporcionada sin que otros a su
alrededor el mundo haya hecho algo para
acabar efectivamente con este
sufrimiento
hace diez años trabajé con niñas
adolescentes que habían nacido durante o
poco después del genocidio en ruanda
durante este genocidio un millón de
personas murió en tan sólo 100 días
otros tres millones de personas fueron
forzados a mudarse a otras partes de su
país oa otros países para salvar sus
vidas
mientras yo escuchaba las historias de
estas niñas visitaba los centros de
memoria y veía las infinitas tumbas
colectivas yo no podía dejar de pensar
como dejamos que esto pase dónde están
las voces de la comunidad internacional
donde estábamos todos nosotros entre
abril y julio de 1994 cuando en ruanda
más de 10.000 personas eran asesinadas
cada día donde estaban ustedes donde
estaba yo y francamente podríamos
hacernos las mismas preguntas sobre casi
cualquier otra crisis humanitaria los 6
millones de judíos que murieron durante
el holocausto nazi o los millones de
desplazados forzados por las guerras
africanas
estos hechos abominables han sucedido en
frente de todos nosotros como dejamos
que esto pase algunos de ustedes podrían
decir bueno pues es que esto pasó hace
mucho tiempo era muy lejos y la verdad
yo no podía hacer mucho ok
aceptemos por un momento esta premisa
entonces qué haríamos si una crisis
humanitaria pasará hoy cerca a nosotros
en nuestros países y justo en nuestra
época nos quedaríamos indiferentes o
esta vez si haríamos algo por mitigar el
sufrimiento de estas personas
ustedes querrían hacer algo
pues les tengo noticias una de esas
tragedias humanitarias está sucediendo
hoy aquí en latinoamérica en tu país en
tu ciudad y sabes que esta vez si tienes
la oportunidad de hacer todo lo que no
hicimos en la crisis de ruanda o en las
crisis de desplazados por las guerras
africanas desde el 2015 unos 5 millones
y medio de venezolanos la quinta parte
de la población de este país ha tenido
que huir de una de las peores crisis que
he sufrido país alguno en la región
ellos han se han ido buscando un mejor
futuro hacia países que no conocen y no
trabajan más y ganan menos que los
locales en donde tienen menor acceso a
salud y educación y en donde diariamente
se enfrentan al abuso a la explotación a
la inequidad y la exclusión este es el
segundo éxodo de población vulnerable
más grande del mundo después de la
crisis siria y a esta crisis humanitaria
que ya era grave se le suma ahora una
pandemia global que hace que este sea
probablemente uno de los peores momentos
en la historia para ser un refugiado
las crisis de el coronavirus nos afecta
a todos sí pero no lo hace por igual
las brechas que ya existían entre la
población venezolana y la población
local en estos países han aumentado y
hoy los venezolanos son más vulnerables
ellos son más pobres tienen más
oportunidad de contagiarse de
coronavirus si se contagian tienen menos
posibilidades de sobrevivir y tienen
menos chances de recuperarse
económicamente que casi cualquier otro
grupo profesional de la región todo esto
en medio de niveles de discriminación y
xenofobia que han alcanzado durante la
pandemia su nivel más alto desde que
inició este exo déjenme les explico a
qué me refiero
y los migrantes y refugiados venezolanos
se están perdiendo de manera
desproporcionada sus trabajos lo que
afecta el bienestar de sus familias
antes del coi 19 la mayoría de estos
migrantes trabajaban en los sectores de
construcción turismo y restaurantes que
han sido algunos de los más afectados
por las normas de aislamiento social
además de eso trabajaban como informales
lo que los ha expuesto más a perder sus
trabajos y caer rápidamente en la
pobreza de hecho antes de la crisis del
coi 19 el banco mundial estimó que en
perú el 18 por ciento de los venezolanos
era pobre después de sólo 30 días de
aislamiento social el 92% de los
venezolanos trabajadores informales
serían pobres estos 74 puntos
porcentuales más en sólo un mes
y a pesar de la crudeza de estos números
muchos podrían decir bueno esto es
terrible pero todos hemos sido afectados
lo mismo de estar pasando con los
trabajadores informales peruanos veamos
el banco también estimó que más o menos
cinco de cada diez trabajadores
informales peruanos habría visto su
ingreso afectado durante este esta
pandemia comparado con 9 de cada 10
trabajadores ven informales venezolanos
los números para los dos grupos son
terribles pero es obvio que la población
venezolana se está viendo afectada de
manera desproporcional y esto sin tener
en cuenta que la población peruana los
trabajadores informales peruanos podrían
acceder al menos alguno de los programas
de ayuda que ha creado el gobierno para
mitigar estas pérdidas programas a los
que la población venezolana no tiene
acceso
y esta situación sería similar en otros
países de latinoamérica en donde están
algunos de los países más afectados por
kobe 19 pero no sólo están perdiendo sus
ingresos de manera desproporcionada
también las familias venezolanas tienen
menores posibilidades de prevenir el
virus la organización mundial de la
salud ha sido categórica en cuanto a las
medidas que son necesarias para prevenir
el coronavirus el distanciamiento social
el uso adecuado de mascarillas y el
lavado frecuente de manos
bueno para muchas de las familias
migrantes y refugiadas venezolanas
adoptar estas medidas es prácticamente
imposible hablemos primero del
distanciamiento social
las familias venezolanas viven en
mayores condiciones de hacinamiento que
la población local en perú por ejemplo
encontramos que el 60% de los
venezolanos viven bajo estas condiciones
esto es 14 veces más que la población
peruana y si hubiesen hacinamiento es
prácticamente imposible tomar la
distancia social requerida para prevenir
el contagio esto quiere decir que un
contagiado en el hogar un en riesgo a
todo el grupo familiar y esta situación
de hacinamiento solamente se ha agravado
durante la pandemia en colombia el grupo
interagencial de flujos migratorios
mixtos encontró que una de cada cinco
familias venezolanas se ha visto forzada
a mudarse durante el periodo de
aislamiento social obligatoria esto
principalmente porque no han tenido con
que pagar sus rentas y esto estas
familias han tenido que mudar
con otras familias o con amigos o lo que
es peor se han visto forzadas a vivir en
la calle entonces descartemos que para
estas familias es posible guardar el
distanciamiento social requerido para
prevenir el virus y qué pasa con otras
medidas como el uso de mascarillas o el
lavado de manos
las mascarillas para ser efectivas deben
cambiarse o lavarse frecuentemente y
esto requiere recursos en colombia se
encontró que dos de cada tres familias
migrantes venezolanas han tenido que
sacrificar al menos una de las tres
comidas necesarias al día entonces estas
familias tienen que escoger entre comer
aún menos o comprar una mascarilla
y cómo lavar las mascarillas o lavarse
las manos frecuentemente si el 30 por
ciento de las familias venezolanas en
colombia no tiene acceso a agua y jabón
cuando lo requiere
como ven estas familias están mucho más
expuestas al contagio
pero además por su vulnerabilidad si se
contagian tendrían menos posibilidades
para sobrevivir a pesar de que los
gobiernos han decretado el acceso
universal a servicios de salud por
afecciones relacionadas al coi la
mayoría de los migrantes y refugiados
venezolanos no busca ayuda médica aún
después de presentar síntomas esto
sucede por varias razones una de ellas
es que muchos no tienen acceso a salud
en colombia en pero usualmente uno de
cada diez migrantes venezolanos tiene un
seguro de salud y por esto ellos piensan
que no van a poder pagar una prueba o
pagar atención médica ni mucho menos una
unidad de cuidado intensivo de requerir
pero además de esto muchos no buscan
ayuda por miedo a la discriminación o
incluso a ser deportados al hacerlo
y podrían salir voces diciendo bueno
esto es una pena pero primero debemos
atender a los nacionales a estas voces
les tengo una noticia el coronavirus no
pide pasaporte y un infectado más en
nuestra comunidad importa porque nos
hace a todos más vulnerables haya nacido
donde haya nacido si algo hemos
sorprendido durante esta pandemia es que
cuidarnos a nosotros solos no es
suficiente tenemos que cuidarnos entre
todos si queremos vencer al coi 19 y
cuando digo todos me refiero a todos
entonces las familias de inmigrantes y
refugiados venezolanos han perdido de
manera desproporcionada sus ingresos se
están viendo más expuestos al
coronavirus y de contraerlo tendrían
menos posibilidades de sobrevivir lo que
les quiero decir es que los riesgos que
ya enfrentaban ellos debido al éxodo se
ha sumado estos riesgos de morir o por
kobe o por hambre durante la pandemia
como pueden ver una crisis humanitaria
está pasando delante de nuestros ojos
y los impactos de esta crisis van a
persistir aún cuando nuestros países
empiecen a recuperarse de la crisis del
cob y la población migrante no va a
poder recuperarse al mismo ritmo
y no van a poder recuperar levantarse de
la pobreza en la que se han sumido a
pesar de que los gobiernos se están
empezando a implementar programas para
redinamizar la economía a través de las
personas a través de las empresas la
mayoría de la población venezolana no se
encuentra incluida en estos programas y
principalmente esto es por su estatus
migratorio irregular y francamente
excluirnos no es una buena idea porque
es precisamente en la inclusión de estas
familias en donde podría estar la clave
para recuperarnos más rápidamente en un
contexto de crisis como el que estamos
viviendo en donde los indicadores de
crecimiento se han desplomado de forma
dramática lo más lógico sería hacer uso
de todas las herramientas que tengamos a
mano para recuperarnos más rápidamente
la población inmigrante y refugiada
venezolana en colombia ecuador y perú
tienen mayores niveles de educación que
la población local pero este potencial
no se está aprovechando
el banco mundial estimó que si la
población venezolana pudiera insertarse
en el mercado laboral peruano podría
producir 3200 millones de dólares
adicionales al año que sería suficiente
para cubrir un tercio del gasto anual en
educación pero además al recibir
ingresos van a comprar otros bienes y
van a pagar impuestos y estos ingresos
serían suficientes no solamente para
proveerles servicios a ellos sino además
de eso para cubrir el presupuesto en el
de todo el departamento del amazonas que
es uno de los más afectados por hoy 19
resultados similares encontramos en
colombia y en ecuador
entonces atender las necesidades de la
población migrante y refugiada no
solamente debería hacerse por razones
humanitarias o por salud pública sino
también porque es un buen negocio para
todos
en este momento en que nuestros países
están atravesando una crisis tan
profunda no podemos darnos el lujo de
desperdiciar una oportunidad así la
población venezolana podría aportar
puntos porcentuales de crecimiento que
hoy necesitamos más que nunca
pero porque no lo hacemos porque no
tomamos medidas de integración y porque
no aprovechamos este potencial si es tan
buen negocio
una de las principales razones es la
xenofobia los en colombia ecuador y perú
los indicadores de rechazo hacia la
población venezolana y desaprobación
hacia las medidas de integración del
gobierno han aumentado de manera
dramática durante la pandemia y este
rechazo impide que los tomadores de
decisiones hagan lo que es más
beneficioso para todos es así como nos
volvemos artífices de la tragedia de
estas familias de migrantes y refugiados
venezolanos pero también de la tragedia
en nuestras propias familias se dan
cuenta debido a la discriminación
podríamos estar perdiendo una
oportunidad cuando la necesitamos más
que nunca
recuerdan que hace unos minutos les
pregunté que harían si graves
injusticias sucederán frente a sus ojos
muchos de ustedes pensaron que les
gustaría hacer algo por aquellas
personas que sufren bueno esta es
nuestra oportunidad y hay mucho por
hacer las familias de migrantes y
refugiados venezolanos necesitan con
urgencia medidas que les permitan
sobrevivir la pandemia y medidas que les
permitan contribuir a la recuperación de
nuestros países
primero ellos necesitan ayuda
humanitaria de emergencia
esto incluye acceso a comida techo de
protección en condiciones que no los
expongan más al contagio como lo está
brindando el gobierno colombiano en las
fronteras con la ayuda de organizaciones
como acnur el programa mundial de
alimentos y la organización
internacional para las migraciones
segundo se debe invertir en las áreas
receptoras para que los locales y los
migrantes y refugiados pueden prevenir
el virus
esto incluye emplear el cubrimiento de
servicios como agua y saneamiento o
salud también implica darles mejor
acceso mascarillas y elementos de
protección y trabajar en las brechas de
servicios que se crean por culpa de
discriminación tercero todos necesitamos
con urgencia que cuanto antes las
familias de inmigrantes y refugiados
venezolanos sean integradas en la
respuesta de nuestros países a la crisis
el primero necesario mantener a estas
familias a flote durante la pandemia
como lo está haciendo el banco mundial a
través de transferencias monetarias por
8 millones de dólares en colombia y en
perú segundo es necesario aprovechar su
capital humano para superar esta crisis
como lo está haciendo argentina y perú
en donde cientos de médicos y enfermeros
venezolanos han sido incorporados al
grupo de profesionales que atiende día a
día a las víctimas de este virus y
finalmente es urgente que la población
venezolana sea incorporada en los
programas de empleo de emprendimiento y
de acceso a créditos para que les
permitan a ellos proveer apoyo a la
recuperación económica a su máximo
potencial y todo lo anterior sería más
fácil si continuamos incentivando la
regularización y la formalización hoy
por hoy en latinoamérica cuatro de cada
diez migrantes es irregular
y esto no les permite acceder a
servicios convalidar sus estudios y
contribuir a nuestras economías como
pueden hacerlo por eso es urgente
reanudar los esfuerzos de regularización
flexibilizar los recursos y flexibilizar
los requisitos y adaptar los procesos a
plataformas virtuales como lo está
haciendo el perú en donde más de 400 mil
migrantes serían regularizados en los
próximos meses y sobre todo hoy más que
nunca necesitamos ser solidarios una
crisis humanitaria está sucediendo
frente a nuestros ojos y aunque como
sociedad hemos hecho esfuerzos para
poder atender esta crisis estos no han
sido suficientes y esta falta de acción
nos afecta a todos afecta la salud
pública de nuestros países
afecta nuestras economías y afecta
nuestra posibilidad de recuperarnos
por eso no podemos quedarnos
indiferentes si uno de nosotros no sale
de esto nadie sale
seamos aquellos que hacen posible que
todos locales migrantes y refugiados
salimos juntos de esta crisis
ponemos organizaciones locales que están
apoyando a la población local vulnerable
y a población migrante y refugiado
apoyemos las respuestas de integración
de nuestros gobiernos y sobre todo
defendamos los de la discriminación y la
xenofobia cada día que pasa y la
situación de estos millones de familias
venezolanas empeora yo me pregunto qué
va a pasar en 10 ó 20 años cuando
abramos los libros de historia y
nuestros hijos lean sobre sexo y lean
como miles de inmigrantes y refugiados
venezolanos murieron por kobe o por
hambre durante esta pandemia nos van a
preguntar si esto sucedió nos van a
preguntar que hicimos que les vamos a
responder que no hicimos nada que le van
a decir ustedes a sus hijos
en un burgués dijo lo único que se
necesita para que el mal triunfe es que
los buenos no hagan nada de que el lado
de la historia de que el lado de esta
historia vamos a estar muchas gracias